33% this left coast show is brought to
you by the Walmart fan shop they got
Nike they got fanatics they got majestic
for all 32 NFL teams I pick some gear I
think you'll like they made a website
for me walmart.com slash bleacher report
go check it out yes
it's bad what is good it is left go show
with the man the myth the legend Warren
sharp we are taking in what happened in
Week three we are looking ahead of what
happened in week four I'm not gonna talk
too much about it warm but it was a good
week for you last week huh felt good it
felt good it felt great to share good
information with 33% get everybody ready
for the games you know try to give them
what they need to be looking for and
then they actually see it happen and
it's a beautiful thing when that when
that works out and I want to tell
everybody two things if you're listening
on audio you're missing out on Warren's
amazing shirt I don't know where he's
been shopping lately but the swag has
been exploding and it's phenomenal and
the two is that Warren and I talked for
a long time last night which means that
today's show is refined and it's full of
good information as always a lot of you
sent me pictures of slips and betting
things that you listened to what we said
and we're never gonna tell you what to
do but we gave you a lot of information
and people actually bet and they made a
lot of money and sharp this is something
you do man and you told me last night if
people want to go to sharp football
analysis you have a code if they want to
get all of your picks from you from the
source and I witnessed it this week
where you said hey I kind of like this
line and then you gave out information
and then I watched 16 casinos 16 sports
books change their lines so what's the
code that the 33% if
want to check out this stuff they can
use on sharp football analysis calm
yeah the code is easy it's just sharp 20
I'm given 20% off everywhere we're not
advertising this anywhere else this is
just for you guys if you're listening to
to our show the left coast show that's
the only people that are going to get
this and mainly it's because we're
talking about a lot of great insight
here but we want to be able to share a
little bit of the detail write-ups and
Nuggets and things of that nature and
get ahead of the line moves like you
mentioned when points are moving when
games are moving by a couple of points
so we want to beat those line moves now
that I'm like seeing this underbelly of
this world war and you're kind of like a
tour guide for me it's wild to watch you
go hey I kind of like this and watch the
number change and before I never knew
that that was even possible
so the things that we're gonna do today
we're gonna take you to sharps school
some information that maybe you didn't
know and some lessons that we've learned
packaged in a way that maybe you could
do something with it we're gonna look at
the big line movements I've tracked how
this has actually impact favorites and
others and how it's gone by looking at
the look ad lines which we do every week
and then we're gonna break down some
prime time games and do some super
contests but we're gonna go to sharp
school and the first thing we're going
to start off with is strength of
schedule a lot of people look at
strength of schedule in terms of 2018
and how you did and and a lot of people
rightly so sharp go that information is
dumb we're basing this off of 2018 well
you're looking at the first three weeks
compared to week four and we're looking
at things like explosive plays and one
of the games that jumped out to you
right away in terms of two teams that
faced certain kind of opponent weeks one
through three and then four was
Washington and New York what jumped off
the page to you yeah so one of the
things that I clearly look out just like
you said is understanding the context of
strength of schedule especially early in
the season and so the thing that jumped
off to me right away for these two teams
is the caliber of defenses that both
faced I mean if you look at the
Washington Redskins they face the fifth
toughest schedule of run defenses so far
this season
I'm
last week obviously we just saw they
played the Chicago Bears and that was
you know Chicago's got a great run
defense prior to that they played the
Dallas Cowboys and prior to that the
Philadelphia Eagles all three of those
teams top ten run defenses two of them
are top five run defenses now they get
to go up against the New York Giants who
ranked 24th against the run and I think
that's gonna be a big edge for the
Redskins in this game similarly they
also play the Giants past defense of
course and that is is there even such a
thing what is the giant madam I mean
Jameis Winston just lit these guys up
they ranked 31st in the NFL right now
and pass defense the Redskins played the
15th toughest schedule year today so
you're moving from like above average in
both of those to like well below average
bottom 10 in pass and run but you know
you would say oh that's a massive edge
for the Redskins and it is it's also an
edge for the New York Giants because the
Redskins defense ranks 27th in passing
and 25th in rushing so they're bad and
the Giants have played the top 10 most
difficult run defenses top 11 most
difficult pass T so they've gone up
against a very difficult schedule as
well so you know you really don't want
to I mean the mainstream and this is
just a little educational nugget we
talked about it this in the off season
Adam the mainstream the looks at
strength of schedule and says what's the
combined win-loss record of what you
played last season and we don't want to
do that we want to look at strength of
schedule based on efficiency metric
based on Las Vegas win totals and now
that we're in the middle of the season
what don't you hear of in the mainstream
media you do not hear any more
discussion about strength of schedule
it's as if every single team because
it's the NFL and there's parity plays
the same exact opponents and everything
is equal nobody talks about in season
strength of schedule and that's one of
the most massive edges that we can get
and it's one of the things that we're
going to be talking about consistently
on this show where every single week so
you found this early on I think it was
Monday
you saw the line the over-under was at
forty seven and this is an example worn
you put some action on it and the line
changed almost immediately
yeah we sent out over 47 and it's now 49
49 and a half and I mean that's a two
two and a half point line move and and
it moves pretty quickly to that number
and it's not a river it's a healthy
number the fact of the matter is you
know based on my new model that I'm
running you know they're they're still
potentially could be a little bit of
value like I still think there might be
more points scored that being said I
would not advocate right now taking 49
49 and a half this thing opened at 46 46
and Hammonds are plots you want to wait
potentially it will come down and you
and I talked about kind of the pros and
cons of of me telling that to people and
then what is actually going to come down
now that I've actually said Oh fine no
no don't wait till it gets to 48 if it
does come back down I think it probably
will a little bit
we'll have to see you know there's some
injury concerns Case Keenum didn't
practice yesterday I Colt McCoy like
they just activated him so we'll see
what the Redskins quarterback situation
ends up looking like the other thing is
it's interesting we kind of go through
the league and we're looking for those
dramatic changes we're a team has faced
an easy schedule for three games and
then it gets harder we just saw in the
Giants Washington they faced a tougher
schedule that suddenly gets easier the
opposite where it suddenly gets tougher
it's a great matchup
it's bills Patriots and you're seeing it
on both sides facing tougher what are we
seeing from the bills perspective in
terms of the defense as they faced
compared to now facing a Patriots
defense with Bill Belichick calling it
it's gonna suddenly get tougher like
that yeah the Buffalo Bills have been
lucky they've been facing the like the
22nd 21st rated schedule of opposing
defenses whether its past versus run and
we know the buff the New England
Patriots defense is ridiculously good
and Buffalo has gone up against I was
just gonna say I put my finger up
because the Patriots are one in both so
the bills are going from 22 and 21 and
past and run and now they're facing the
number one toughest defense in both the
run in the pass and so we're gonna learn
a lot about Josh Allen this weekend yeah
we are now the interesting thing is if
you look at the Patriot to me
they face the Miami Dolphins who clearly
are not good they face the New York Jets
who were playing without Sam Darnell so
maybe that defense is not like the
absolute best by far in the NFL but I
will say that defense is really good we
predicted it coming into the season that
if the Patriots didn't have Josh Gordon
didn't have in Tony Brown and obviously
don't have Robert Kowski this defense is
capable of carrying this team and I
think this defense is certainly gonna be
capable of slowing down this Buffalo
Bills offense which has played the
Giants that we talked about and the
Cincinnati Bengals just last week
pundits as well yeah and the Jets as
well on the Jets had Arnold that game
sure buddy Phil was a defense that they
could take advantage of on the flip side
the New England Patriots they've faced
some easy defenses themselves you know
we just talked about a couple of those
games that played the Miami Dolphins
overall the New England Patriots have
played the 24th ranked schedule of
opposing past defenses now they have to
go up against the Buffalo Bills who have
the number four ranked schedule of past
defense so the new wing of Patriots are
going to need to lean a little bit more
on the run game and we'll talk about
this a little bit later what might be
the implications because of injuries at
their fullback position will die out
looking forward to breaking that down
that combined with the Harrison Phillips
starting nose tackle for the Buffalo
Bills is out which makes you think the
Patriots kind of want to attack that
that line over under 42 and a half look
we're talking about Giants Washington
getting suddenly easier
Patriots pills getting suddenly harder
the line of 42 and a half kind of pops
out to you a little bit yeah it's tough
I mean there's it's hard to go under in
a game with with Tom Brady and the
Patriots dropping you know 42 42 point
total but the key is there is a key
number involved here and that's 41 41
hits fairly often in totals and so you
know if you were to go under this game
and this total happen to drop lower you
wouldn't want to take anything worse
than 41 mmm being said you know I don't
think that's an issue right now it's
certainly not right now and I doubt it
would get below 41 close to kickoff is
just a super super low total but when
you look at the way that this game sets
up again we'll discuss it
seems like we're gonna get a little bit
of a grinder probably early on in this
game especially because as I've been
saying all week last year Patriots at
Buffalo Derick Anderson four days off
the golf course Buffalo was heading in
to the fourth quarter with the Patriots
down nine to six and it took an 84 yard
pick six from Devin McCourty last year
to really bust that game open and that
total went under 42 so we'll see again
it's Josh Allen's an interesting
quarterback for the Patriots to defend
but those are the two strengths of
schedules from week ones through three
to four that are more the more dramatic
ones that we can pay attention to that
other people aren't paying attention to
we're gonna stay in sharp school but
right now Lauren I'm hearing some rumors
in the hallway I'm hearing some people
talking some crap and I don't know if
they know exactly what they're talking
about everybody watched Sunday nights
came and it was browns Rams and we're
focusing right now on Freddie kitchens
and everybody's talking about how a lot
of three wide receivers sets that's
something that you've been spotlighting
all off really the first three weeks but
also should he turn the play calls over
to Todd Monken maybe he's not ready for
it and Warren we talked about it last
night
you're actually thinking maybe they're
listening to Todd Monken too much I'm
not hearing this anywhere and part of
the reason is you're seeing so much 11
personnel for everybody that's three
wide receivers one running back one
tight end but you think that's the Todd
Monken special and people might actually
have it backwards right now yeah Todd
Monken came in in the offseason and put
his influence into this offense now
Freddie kitchens physically calls the
plays but one of the biggest things that
we saw last year when Freddie kitchens
got involved with the Browns and turned
this offense around from what Hugh
Jackson had it was he utilized a lot
more 12 personnel when he came in that
offense dropped down to only 68 percent
of passes came out of 11 personnel when
Freddie kitchens was there in 2018
that's well that's below average by
several percentage points and they were
really efficient when they passed out of
twelve and thirteen twelve is two tight
ends 13 is three tight ends so they had
extra blockers in there to help make
life easier on later mate they averaged
67 percent success rate in either case
when they passed out of 12 or 13 and
average 9.6 yards per attempt out of 12
and eleven point seven yards per attempt
out of 13 but in 2019 because of two
things I think the first one being
injury at tight end position obviously
David and Joe ku is out the prime
through that even week one they're using
a lot of 11 personnel like ninety-one
percent up from 68 percent to ninety one
percent that's correct
it's a huge increase I think they had
one pass out of an on 11 personnel
grouping in week one of the season and
that was one in joke who was healthy
that is Todd Monken influence in my
opinion
Freddie kitchens didn't come in last
year and do that now you could have the
situation where both guys think it's
smart because we've got three great wide
receivers why not put them out on the
field more but I think the issue right
now is past protection you've got to
make Baker Minnifield feel comfortable I
noticed it even last year when Baker was
getting pressured and there were bodies
around him he just did not have the same
efficiency in the pocket but that
offensive line was better and they used
an extra tight end to block more now
your offensive line is weaker you're not
using extra tight end to block his
pasture rating we talked about on the
show last week very low when it comes to
when he's under pressure and using so
much 11 personnel has definitely
impacted his ability to find success
this matchup turning the page forward to
this week interesting because they're
playing the Baltimore Ravens who really
struggle we've talked about it yeah
three wide receivers are more on the
field yep absolutely so the issue is
good not going to be should they not use
it here I think they probably should but
you've got to figure out a way to slow
that pass rush down from the Baltimore
Ravens because if that's pass rush
messes up with Baker Mayfield especially
early in that game it's not going to be
good for Cleveland yeah my big counter
to that coaching staff would be like
sure in the preseason you had three
really good wide receivers we haven't
seen a full strength of chard Higgins
all season thus far so
they're throwing in some other guys in
that third wide receivers spot that I
don't even know if they warrant that
amount of tension on the field as you
mentioned within Jo ku being out it's
putting Demetrius Harris who many people
classify more as a wide receiver a pass
catcher than an inline blocker and
Rickey seals Jones who literally was a
wide receiver in college and so it makes
you kind of look at where are they
blocking and then we factor in trading
Kevin Zeidler this offseason and the
weekend offensive line the one thing
that I always learned from Warren is we
can make it obvious that a team needs to
change but we never really know if a
coach is gonna see it we think that
they're gonna be smart enough and
realize that themselves
so Warren the question I asked for you
is we've hammered at home now three
weeks in a row the Browns are obsessed
with three wide receivers on the field
and it's hurting them
when will you know that they've learned
from their mistake and how do you learn
while we can we can really bet against
this because they just can't get off it
when do we realize the wells run dry
from a coaching intelligence perspective
right well the hard part is you know I
work for some NFL teams as a consult and
I'm able to like share provide some
information even when I'm doing that
it's not fully known ahead of the game
whether or not they're going to
implement that right I'm providing this
information to them to try to make them
aware of it and try to help them in
their matchup Kai's are stubborn men
they really are some of them can be and
and you know they might think well this
is good information but I think we've
got a little edge in this matchup here
so let's try it this other way it's it's
no fault of theirs that they might want
to try something different but in this
case with you know what Freddie kitchens
is doing it's certainly been presented
hard enough by me into the media into
the Twitterverse that I think they've
probably been made aware of this but
again will they do anything about it
this particular game against the Ravens
when the Ravens are susceptible to what
they susceptible they're susceptible
because they've had two injuries in that
secondary two starters one was in the
offseason one was early and they are
down bodies and so when you spread them
out you're having more success even
last week we talked about on this show
we talked about the fact that Patrick
mahomes and the Kansas City Chiefs were
probably a more success in 11 and
they've been using a lot more 11 so far
this year what did they do in an out of
11 against the Ravens this past week out
of 11 three wide receivers again 12
point 2 yards per attempt but when they
went well they only averaged 6.3 yards
per attempt almost half okay and when
they were and and they had a much higher
passer rating and yards per attempt when
they were passing out of 11 they
actively in creased their usage of 12
from the year-to-date average however I
think in part because that pass rush was
giving Patrick mahomes a few problems
and was more beneficial for Andy Reed to
say look we got to mix up enough 12 in
here so that we're helping the Homes a
little bit more often but their run game
was substantially more efficient out of
11 as well 73 percent success rate 8.8
yards per carry out of 11 when they were
12 that was 8.8 was down to 3.3 so they
were much better running out of 11 to
I'm cautiously optimistic that
Cleveland's going to normally in
situations like this I think that it's
better not to bet on a change you should
bet that the coach is going to do the
same types of things that he's been
doing until we see with our own eyes
otherwise and that way we approach this
particular game and again in this
particular game it's not a bad thing but
in terms of like being able to bet when
is a coach going to change when are they
going to adapt I think you bet that the
coach is more likely to do what he's
been doing year-to-date with a couple
rare exceptions one of which being a go
Bella check who game plans for their
opponents better than anybody else in
the league let's go into Bella check
because we're gonna say this is the last
lesson of sharp school today Bill
Belichick has had a few people on his
team that are non-negotiable they're
making the roster Phil Simms used to
joke with me this all the time he'd say
Adam who were the three guys that are
guaranteed to make the Patriots roster
this year and I would go Tom Brady he's
go yet I
Oh Matthew Slater and he'd go yep and
I'd go Pat Devlin and he go you nailed
it
Belichick cares about his quarterback
his special teams ace and his fullback
I'm gonna go through a little bit of
statistics that Warren told me last
night about the Patriots and their
obsession with the fullback and more and
I'll turn it to you afterwards but 21
personnel okay that's two running backs
one tight end and for the Patriots
that's a fullback and that's a running
back the league average is 11% the
Patriots ran at 38% of the time so they
are so far above the league average of
using a fullback it's crazy now we just
talked about how the league average 411
which again three wide receivers one
tight end run one running back it's the
most popular formation the league that
Warren is found the league average is 64
percent of the time 64 percent of the
time the league is tried now three wide
receivers one running back one tight end
the Patriots ran it 53% of the time
which is very low a huge gap between the
rest of the league the question though
is now with the running back with with
the full-back being gone what do you
think Warren are they gonna go more
towards 11 or like what personnel could
we expect will we see Birkhead and James
White on the field together why Sony
Michele will we see two tight ends one
running back what if your statistics
shown about what the Patriots will do
now that Devlin is gone I think that
we're going to see enough enough 11
personnel out of them that it's going to
augment the the loss but B and they're
really good out of 11 - they're not just
good out of 21 with back out there
they're really good out of 11 but what
they love not just that they pass out of
21 either because they do but it's not
as if they're more efficient passing out
of 21 than they are are out of they just
like to mix it up for the defense's and
be able to dictate you know gain when
Jade Evelyn was on the field
Sonne Michelle that's how he scored
all of his touchdowns in the postseason
last year Tony Michelle did not have a
single rushing touchdown in the playoffs
last year when they won the Super Bowl
without James Devlin being on the field
as his lead blocker
so it's not as if they couldn't do it
from 11 but they like the physicality
and what that brings the style to their
offense and it's going to be unfortunate
that they don't have that now what would
you say that the New England Patriots
are one of the best in the league at
offsetting losses on game planning on
figuring things out
so guarantee they're going to try some
other things but what if that 11
personnel doesn't have the same punch
because you can't bring the full back
out there on occasion and utilize that
at the second highest rate of any team
in the NFL that that is going to hurt
them a little bit and it's going to
affect them far more than any other team
because of how much they use that full
back out on the field in this particular
game they're playing the Buffalo Bills
the Buffalo Bills really good against
the pass struggle like about average
slightly below average against the run
they're also without their starting nose
tackle so you can guarantee that the
Patriots are not going to be like oh
crap we don't have Devlin we're just
going to throw the ball a lot this week
they're still going to run possibly at
the same or more than they normally
would based upon the strength of the
Buffalo Bills defense but it is a major
factor in the philosophy of Bill
Belichick and this Patriots offense
moving forward so this is a wait-and-see
see how he sort of changes his offense
because I know you did the research
the Patriots actually went a lot of 20
in week one which is two running backs
no tight ends and you told me that it
went so poorly that they haven't run it
since and then I asked you well maybe
they go to tight ends one running back
and and you said that they're running
that 5% of the time which is is that the
lowest in the NFL so these other options
that they might be able to do they have
not shown either success doing it or a
wanting this to do it yeah in week one
I'm not quite sure why they tried to
utilize a lot of 20 I think it was
because you know Matt Lacoste and their
tight ends they're not Rob Gronkowski so
like look let's just put two fullbacks
and spread the field with three wives
running back in a fullback spread to
fill with three
they ran 33 snaps out of 20 personnel
they averaged just a 45 percent success
rate passes from Brady average only 5.2
yards per attempt rut a virgin only
three point one guess what they adapted
week to scratch it they didn't use
anymore 20 personnel and obviously
without Devlin I don't think they're
gonna use a lot of 20 personnel so
they're very adaptable but you're
absolutely right it is going to be a
factor in kind of on their their
philosophy and their approach and we'll
see we'll wait and see what they end up
doing and what success they end up
having this week against the bills I
believe it is my responsibility
Warren provides a lot of the information
I try to give the view from 30,000 feet
as a normal [ __ ] that just
happens to love football and when I
asked him last night he kept saying you
know they run two running backs one
tight end the second most in the NFL and
they run three wide receivers second
least in the NFL and I said Warren who
runs it more and who then them and he
goes Kyle Shanahan this is what I have a
question for the rest of the NFL
Patriots they run two running backs one
tight end the second most at 38% Kyle
ran it at 40 and then I book the whole
NFL runs three wide receivers balichek
does the second-most 11 percent less
well guess what the league runs three
wide receivers one running back one
tight end at 64% Kyle Shanahan runs it
at 39% if you did a chart it would be so
far down that you'd go that is an
outlier we can't include it in it but
I'd ask any football fan out there whose
offense would you want to emulate more
the Patriots and thus and Kyle Shanahan
Bill Belichick and Kyle Shanahan or the
rest of the NFL and it makes me want to
ask every coach out there are you blind
because they're showing you how to do
this and no one's listening Lauren I
feel like I'm taking crazy pills well
look the issue is everybody thinks that
the the full-back is dead nobody uses a
fullback anymore so you know it's all
spread offense and air raid principles
coming in
wide receiver sets and what I've been
finding and I was like banging this drum
for the past couple of years because I'm
looking at these personnel group you
sound like look three wives is great but
actually passing out of a little bit of
heavier set provide so much more plus CV
so much better expected value because
the defense doesn't know you're gonna be
asked out of those sets they're
anticipating a run is going to happen
and that's one of the reasons why I mean
how Shanahan is next level did you see
that past the cow use check caught down
Pittsburgh Steelers I mean first of all
use check like he's getting paid a lot
he's a stud at his position so he's
capable of making those place not not
most full backs are but the value of
having guys like fullbacks who can be
multi-dimensional they can help in Pass
Pro they can go out on wheel routes they
can lead block for a running back in
having those jackknife like Swiss Army
knife pieces that can do a lot of things
and that prevents predictability is the
key to winning in the NFL it's removing
the aspect of predictability and that's
the biggest problem with offenses around
the league is when they become too
predictable
that's when they're giving the chips
back to the defense and we're gonna
preach this all season long offenses
need to based upon personnel before the
snap up and pre snap motion before the
snap try to fool the defense or get Keys
off the defense after that snap post
snap motion as well we're talking play
action here we're talking like some jet
sweep motion those types of things also
confuse the defense when you're
implementing those things and you're
using various different personnel
groupings with different the same guys
but in different roles on the very piece
you are going to cause confusion and
conflict for that defense and make a
tough job much more difficult for them
I'll sum it up with one statistic that's
happened through three weeks this year
Kyle Shanahan is running three wide
receivers one running back one tight end
39% of the time their offense has topped
in almost every metric and the three
know the
Browns are running that same formation
91% of the time their offense is in the
bottom of almost everything and their
own three excuse me their one and two
and they beat Luke Falk and the New York
Jets
excuse me wanted to and I just think
sometimes it's very clear and as a
football fan we we want to blame a
quarterback and and how he's not great
or we want to blame a coach and and
sometimes it's just very simple and we
want to give you that information and
explain how football can be that simple
let's take a look at line movements you
ready for it yep okay so the one thing I
did learn is I went back and I
calculated the last three weeks of the
big line moves that we've seen and I
wanted to see if it moved to a favorite
how did the favorite do if it moved away
from the favorite how did the favorite
do through the first three weeks
comparing the look-ahead line which is
the line that came out last Thursday
compared to the line at the West Gate
for the Super contest right now when the
line grew towards a favorite the
favorite covered there there were four
and nine against the spread
two of the four was the Pats and Dolph
was the Pats and Dallas against Miami
which I do not believe Miami is a team
that we can include in this personally
that's just me so which means that the
only two teams in which the line which
the public got more excited about and
started betting on a favorite more was
last week Chicago against Washington
which to me also feels like another
special circumstance and then also
Minnesota against Oakland when the line
shrank the favorite was three and two so
not as as as indicative and when the
favorite flipped the favorite was two
and one but for me the fact that as the
favorites have grown they're only
covering the spread and I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm personally and you tell me if
I'm just doing this to make my point
better removing the Patriots in Dallas
covering the spread 2 out of 11 times I
think that's a little eye-opening for me
I think it's fair to remove them when
you're talking about because you're
removing the Miami Dolphins games and
that's a team that just really isn't
putting a competitive
product out on the football field right
now so I don't see any issue with
removing that and 2 and 11 is certain I
mean 2 & 9 9 ok 2 & 9 out of 11 ah very
eye-opening so with that I wanted to
focus on who were the teams that got
juiced up as favorites because we are
Rijn at reactionary humans and we watch
games and the first one is guess who
Ravens Browns Ravens a week ago when the
lines first came out was a three and a
half point favorite over the Browns the
Ravens go in there and they hang with
the Chiefs the Browns go there on
national television and can't they look
inept against the Rams and the line move
from three and a half to the Ravens to
six and a half to the Ravens I just
think it's pretty incredible though that
we have this one notion where the Browns
are obsessed with three wide receivers
and the Ravens weakness is facing three
wide receivers without Jimmy Smith on
the field and it's a divisional game and
the Browns are desperate and it just
kind of opens my eyes with the two and
nine and all of those factors that we've
laid out for people yeah and you we're
talking about the fact that maybe
Cleveland this is the time that you want
to be an 11 personnel right against the
vault because this is the time it's not
going to be easy for Cleveland in this
going on the road you know somewhat of a
shorter week especially compared to what
the Ravens were dealing with and you
know the Ravens historically good home
splits for the quarterbacks they
typically do very well at home but what
I will say is at home against the
Arizona Cardinals week to a rookie head
coach a rookie quarterback first start
on the road for both of those guys and
they were able to move the ball
consistently into the Ravens red zone
and what did we notice about the Arizona
Cardinals last week when they played the
Carolina Panthers that passing game was
efficient short but they couldn't open
it up and Kyle Emery was under constant
pressure they were able to do a little
bit better against the Baltimore Ravens
from those spread formations a week ago
in Baltimore
you know the prior week in right oh that
I mean I am certain
not running to delay the Baltimore
Ravens here I want to I want to believe
in Freddie kitchens because I love what
he was doing last week what I want him
to do is adapt a little bit this week I
want to see if they're gonna utilize
some things to help Baker Mayfield out a
little bit more is he going to become
that QB friendly coach that Andy Reed is
Andy Reed is so good I mean you look at
patch from a homes he's a freak
right pinion a patch of my home's
greatest of all time I think you've said
most talented most talented Patrick
mahomes is a stud but guess what Andy
Reed makes his life easier so it looks
even better for Patrick in a home when
he's putting up these numbers because
Andy Reed is such a QB whisperer I want
for any kitchens to come in here I want
him to be able to figure out a way to
make Baker Mayfield look better figure
out a way to have let Baker's pocket
presence and awareness in the pocket be
maximized so that they have an easier
time against this Ravens defense I
really want to watch and see how that
goes down a next line that got juiced up
for a favorite
this is a road favorite the Chiefs they
started off last Thursday as four and a
half point favorites at the Lions Lions
go into Philadelphia they win Chiefs
look immaculate again that line has
moved from the Chiefs favor by four and
a half it's in the super contests are
favored by six and a half again as I
said the beginning of this segment the
favorites as they get juiced up have not
done great at covering the spread I know
that you noticed here the Lions actually
have a strength of schedule advantage
against the Chiefs in terms of the
opponents they face thus far this season
yeah they do the Detroit Lions so far
this season when you look at some of
their difficulties that they've had like
their offense hasn't looked quite as you
know I mean it was coming together early
on in the season but Detroit one of the
things what did we know that they want
to do and they showed us this last year
they want to be able to run yes and so
far they've played the 15th most
difficult schedule of run defenses
Kansas City is the worst run defense in
the NFL and I'll go back again to that
Baltimore game
what did we see when Baltimore played
Arizona and again we're kind of hopping
around here but let's play the south
when Baltimore played Arizona they're
running back struggled to run the
football Lamar Jackson had to run a lot
that game set a record in how much he
ran Baltimore goes into Kansas City last
week on the road and they're having
great game out of their running backs
remember mark Ingram's busting Rondo
Edwards yeah yeah they were having a
great day running they couldn't do that
at home the week before against Arizona
I think it's big for the Detroit Lions
to be able to run the football in this
game have that opportunity to be very
balanced if they want to and not be in
predicaments where we're running the
ball we're very run heavy on early downs
but that's forcing us to go into second
and long third and long they'll probably
be somewhat productive if they do choose
to run the ball on first down and again
the advice is don't run the ball so much
on first down but we have to handicap
not just we want teams to do based on
efficiency but we know their coaches now
what do we think they're gonna do
probably run on first down in this game
it might be successful that could help
this offense overall set them up for
easier second and third and third down
situations I think it's very beneficial
for them here and then on the reverse I
know you were talking to me last night a
little bit about the defense of Matt
Patricia and we're going to have to deal
with and his success against Andy Reid's
offense in the past and may well dig
into that a little bit when we start
breaking this game down in more detail
let's do let's do it right now because I
look at Patricia and I see that you know
Belichick has had success relatively
against Patrick mahomes I mean he still
put out like 35 and 41 but if you look
at Patrick mahomes in the last game at
least in the AFC Championship it was a
lot of screens there's a lot of dump
offs and it wasn't a lot of the
downfield attacks that we've seen yeah
I'm curious because you look Detroit
they've held the under in their last
five games at home but it's it's such a
differing styles where the Lions want to
run it and the Chiefs
always want to pass it but I'm curious
from what you found what did you find in
terms of
Patricia's ability to slow down this
offense yeah it is going to be
interesting he knows the good part is
you know again putting the chips in your
favor
Patricia knows what this Chiefs team is
going to try to do against them he's had
a lot of experience running this very
similar defense against this team
multiple times in the past so he knows
what Andy Reed wants to do they don't
have Tyreke Hill but they're fine
without Tyreke Hill because Nicole
Hardman has really offsets that law but
you're right it's it's a really unique
style because the Chiefs are the second
most pass heavy team in the league
Detroit is the sixth most run-heavy team
in the league so you got a team that
really wants to pass the ball a lot
versus a team that really wants to run
the ball a lot the interesting thing
here that I'm going to be looking
forward to is this Chiefs offense has
struggled a little bit in the red zone
and one of the reasons is they don't
have that go to run that running back
that they can count on down in the red
zone with creamy cream hunt not being
there and that's putting more pressure
on Patrick Holmes to be a stud down
there and maybe he's gonna be just fine
in the long term but in this particular
game with a little bit of insight of
what Patricia knows that they might want
to try to do in the red zone could that
be the difference I mean we're talking
about a spread that's below a touchdown
right now and a line where it sort of
looks to me it's hard for me not to say
Detroit could be the side here I you
know I'd rather have the seven but it's
hard for me to want to run to back
Kansas City with the NFL's worse run
defense on the road in this spot against
a team that wants to run the ball
probably will try to run the ball and
keep in mind you know this this rushing
attack from the Detroit Lions know what
ranks 26th in the league they've played
the 13th tough to schedule of run
defenses so far and now they being
easiest to run defense maybe that's a
different how do you have you seen this
before where you have one style and then
versus the complete opposite style and
is there is there a way to figure out
who's gonna win that battle is this
something that you're gonna watch the
game and you're going
see the pace of the game and then you do
more of an in-game bet for an over like
a total here or a total whether it's an
under or an over based on how the games
going like how can we figure this out
ahead of time or is it something where
we're just gonna figure out when that
when the ball gets kicked off well I am
never a fan of teams trying to
intentionally go slow to limit and other
teams offense but that being said I mean
the Detroit Lions are 17th and adjusted
pace of play so they're basically league
average they're not like super slow
they're not super fast and there's no
real like hard and fast golden rule of
which style will win out which team will
win out it's always matchup based on a
particular game every single week it
varies a little bit one of the things
that stands out to me is that the
Detroit Lions pass defense is the 10th
best in the league and so yes the Kansas
City Chiefs have the best passing
offense and they love to pass the
football second-most in the NFL
they've also faced the 25th ranked
schedule of opposing past defenses
playing the 10th most difficult schedule
of a tempo difficult opponent in pass
defense so that is something to take
into consideration as well but I don't
know just like across the board if
there's anything that we should say well
this typically would happen in this spot
I think this matchup based game it is
interesting Mike Daniels did leave the
game against Philadelphia with an injury
and Darius slay left now Darius slay
wasn't practiced this week he was
limited but he is going and I think
that's huge because I do believe he's
one of the best corners the NFL right
now just for people that are out there
the public money is all over Kansas City
68% of the money right now is going
towards Kansas City that's when uber
sent me this morning so look the public
loves Kansas City and to be honest as a
better it's hard to want to watch a game
and go
I need Patrick mahomes in his first dome
game in the history of his career to
have a slow start but I look at the
Detroit Lions defense and I see a team
that's invested in the defensive line
not just in Trey flowers but in their
draft picks with a Shawn Robinson and
Deshawn hand
and in my Daniels and I see a team that
might have a chance to stop the run by
only putting down four people and when I
see Patricia and I know that he's gonna
know what Belichick did whether it's
showing stuff and disguising Patricia
has stopped a lot of offenses in Detroit
remember they beat New England in
Detroit last year they slowed down Cam
Newton in Carolina to a crawl last year
in Detroit but this is another beast and
as somebody that loves the Chiefs and
loves making money it's a scary thought
on Sunday to sit there and go I'm
betting against Patrick mahomes but I
don't think there's any value in in
laying that seven with the Chiefs so
it'll be interesting anything else you
wanted to add there before I move on to
the next line movement no I think I
think we've covered that one and I would
agree one of the other interesting
factors here is we know Annie Reed loves
to throw the football two running backs
that's a big part of this offense it
doesn't happen frequently but it happens
for big explosive plays the Lions
defense so far year-to-date is number
nine defending running back passes in
terms of efficiency you know I don't
think it's gonna you know Andy reads a
totally different beast but it tell us
to consider that's good information the
this is a question I had for you the
Patriots line was six and a half
favorite last week they're now a
seven-point favorite how big of a deal
is it that it went from the six and a
half to the seven um let me see this
line well what we've seen is that this
line actually you write six and a half
but that's sort of what it opened at and
now it's been bet a little bit more to
seven gosh so from that perspective like
what we didn't see with the with the
openers at Westgate or any sports book
out there what we want to look at is for
the look of headlines we want to see
when did the odds maker like open this
totally different than what it was set
on the look ahead and in this case they
didn't open it that definitely um within
a half a point and then and a little bit
more with New England money up to the
seven so I don't really see obviously
there's a massive difference between six
and a half and seven right
and of like something to glean from this
I don't see anything
who I just I just wanted to check
because I know that there's a lot of
times where we'll advise people hey
listen I know you like it at six and a
half but it might be better at seven
just because it's a little bit safer but
it's not a drastic one I just wanted to
check on that and we did talk about how
how both teams are facing a much more
difficult defense this week and I think
it's interesting when the Patriots when
you factor in the defensive coordinators
they face thus far Greg Williams who has
been shown time and time again to be
kind of a joke
Keith Butler who you have shown on
Twitter what the Steelers is constantly
showing himself as a joke and his
disciple Bryan Flores who is coaching a
junior varsity team there in Miami the
Patriots with Sean McDermott are
experiencing a whole nother team but not
enough of a big line change the other
big line change here worn Seattle going
to Arizona a week and a half ago or we
could go from today they were a three
point favorite
now after Arizona gets dusted by the
Panthers they are a five point favorite
the Seahawks are and what I what I
really want to focus on is this is more
of an X's and O's thing so this is last
betting more X's and O's all I heard
about was how cliff Kingsbury's offense
it's a 40 so it's it's for wide
receivers no tight ends one running back
ten personnel is what it's called but
four wide receivers in what matters is
how this is gonna take over the NFL and
what's funny is last night I go Warren
I'll tell you what man this offense
wasn't looking good second half against
Detroit I'm seeing Kyler dish in the
ball you know that game against
Baltimore I know he's going deep to
Damir bird and he's hitting Larry
Fitzgerald they're putting up yards but
then I said man so tell me about this
for wide receiver offense it's much it's
better been great and you compared it to
puking all over yourself you told me
that it's the opposite and this
Cardinals for wide receiver offense has
not been good what have you found
well so 61% of their plays have come
from ten
personnel the league average including
their 61% is 4% okay so the rest of the
cow where the rest of the league rarely
runs this this style of for wide
receivers
when they're out there in four wide
receivers though it's positive for the
run game spread out the defense David
Johnson is having success they're
averaging four point eight yards per
carry and a fifty four percent success
rate but they're only running 22% of the
time out of four wide receiver sets it's
it's it's basically they're passing
offense they're passed it when they're
in that about eight out of every ten
plays they're gonna be passing the
football then the problem is because
they're so poor in this ten personnel
with those four wides it's affecting
their overall offense they're only
averaging 6.1 yards per attempt and a 36
percent success rate out of that 10
personnel and we saw that come to
fruition against the Carolina Panthers
last week in that game Kyler Murray very
efficient with these short passes and
lots of open guys but very difficult to
move the ball down the field and then
what ends up happening when you're not
getting and we'll talk about this later
I think a balance of efficient versus
explosive right you want to be efficient
but you want to have some chunk plays
because what happens is with a line like
Arizona we talked about that entering
the season they don't have a lot of
talent on that line it almost literally
killed Josh Rosen last season so don't
have a lot of talent on that line and
they use wide splits and they go a lot
of 10 personnel which means no tight end
which means very little pass Pro to help
out Kyler Murray if you sustain a sack
on a drive and you're dinking and
dunking and getting from five yards and
six yards on these past times it's good
also you lose like seven yards on a sack
you're not going to be able to offset
that on second and third down to get
back on track to convert a first down
like this is an offense right now that
can't afford to be sacked
they've been sacked 11 times out of a
hundred drawbacks
when they're in 10 personnel and those
are like drive killers for a team that
can't get an explosive gain in the
passing game so it has not
worked thus far it's helped the run game
but they need to run the ball more out
of it maybe don't pass eight out of ten
times maybe past six out of ten times
from it be a little bit more balanced
and and try to do a better job of
protecting Kyler Murray when you're
spreading out that defense the other
thing though is they're playing a
Seattle team that I think everyone still
thinks the Adil's defense is good even
though New Orleans kind of went all over
and less last week and look bangles put
up but you looked at in you said it's
simply the people they've played this
might actually be a good matchup for the
Arizona offense the Seattle defense
might not be as good as anyone's
thinking they are no there's I think
there's definite edges for the for the
Arizona Cardinals offense here if you
look at who Seattle's faced this is
again there's like the layers that I
love sharing I get so jazzed up for this
out of because this is my wheelhouse
it's understanding the context not just
the statistics okay
the Seattle defense ranked 17th against
the past so you're like okay this is a
league average past defense look at who
they have played week 1 they played Andy
Dalton Andy Dalton
great day you shared last night the
statistics that Andy Dalton put up that
week one game love the NFL week 2 they
play an injured Ben Roethlisberger for
the first half of the game and then they
yanked been completely out of the
football game they played a backup
quarterback who was not prepared to
start that game and who had very little
real game experience and he still led to
touchdown drives to Vance McDonald there
you go then week three they go and guess
who they get the Saints but without Drew
Brees the first game that Drew Brees
can't play Teddy Bridgewater yes he did
have a week to prepare yes we took the
Saints plus three in the first half we
talked about it on the show last week
that being said Teddy Bridgewater did OK
in that game he didn't have a high yards
per attempt but he was very efficient
passing the football I think like a 55
percent success rate on his passing
attempts and that was on the road in a
dome outdoors when they're used to
playing in a dome in the rain and they
ended up doing fairly well with
bridgewater who is not nearly the
caliber of a starter quarterback in the
NFL and Sean Payton had to do a lot of
different things
he basically thrown the ball to just two
dudes throwing the ball to Alvin Kamara
ton and Michael Thomas Thomas a time
that was pretty much it that's all their
efficiency so and and that by the way
your that this is something we should
know we talked about earlier how home it
is not worth as much as it once was and
now there's a difference in home-field
advantage this is a situation where
home-field advantage was a massive jump
you take the Saints away from their home
dome where they're used to all the crowd
noise and send them to Seattle an
outdoor game on the road where they're
playing in the elements and the crowd
noise up there that was a big
disadvantage for the Saints and the
Saints were still able to be productive
offensively through the air against this
defense so Arizona at home being able to
pass the ball against the defense that I
think has probably been inflated in
terms of their numbers it looks a little
bit better than what they are they've
played six of their last twelve six of
their 12 quarters this season against
backup quarterbacks and the only full
game that they faced a real quarterback
was Andy Dalton two weeks three weeks
ago I mean I think that there's some
opportunity for Kyler Murray and this
Arizona Cardinals passing attack the
last three times that Arizona has hosted
Seattle and think about how Bad's
Arizona has been the last three years
and the fact that Seattle's pretty much
made the playoffs every year they lost
by three they lost by six and they tied
six to six and I do know that we've
talked about before Arizona has a
home-field advantage that a lot of
people don't realize it's not a home
it's not Kansas City it's it's not one
of these places where it's known but
it's there and it's real and I know that
you look at this team and there's gonna
be opportunities for Seattle's offense
to put up points but it's gonna require
them to pass the ball and we know that
the Seattle Seahawks have a tendency to
be obsessed with running the ball and it
just it could turn into something but
it's one of those things again we don't
know what Seattle's gonna do if they
pass they could have success I just
don't know what they're gonna do Arn
that's the tough part here you know
Brian Schottenheimer really loves to run
the football they have they've had in
the front I think in the first half
again it was 12 second and 10 plus yards
to go very bad situations and he's run
the ball 50% of the time in those
situations those run plays are gaining
1.3 yards per carry they have one of the
most run heavy rates in the NFL to start
games and this is one of the reasons why
we liked the New Orleans Saints last
week why do we take them in the first
half instead of the full game because I
don't want to deal with petty
Bridgewater for four quarters number one
but number two we know that's this the
Seattle Seahawks and Brian Armour
specifically start off slow in this game
they got to break some tendencies
they've got some really well defined
tendencies that any DC should be looking
at these guys love to around the
football they love to run the football
on first down guess what could happen if
they chose to break those tendencies
here the Arizona Cardinals defense is
one of the worst in two situations
they're terrible if they think it's
going to be run based on the personnel
grouping if you use 12 personnel they're
terrible
yes and you if you put two tight ends on
the field and they think oh they might
run it
their defense stinks their defense
thinks because they start playing the
run and they were down two starters in
that secondary and they leaders from yep
they don't have as much talent then
right exactly Robert and then the other
scenario where they're also bad is if
you use play action where you trick the
defense to think that it after the snap
it could be Iran they come up they bite
they get all their spacing gets messed
up they leave guys uncovered and tight
ends have absolutely been killing them
this could be a really good game for
will dis Lee for all you fantasy DFS
players out there but I definitely think
that the Seattle Seahawks if they choose
to pass the ball more on first down and
if they choose to utilize some more play
action and get aggressive through the
air the Seattle Seahawks are getting
ready to play a couple of really good
pass defenses in fact their strength to
schedule out past defenses the rest of
the year is the hardest in the league
Wow they're going to be times when
they're going to need to
rely a little bit more on the run game
because the past defenses are so good
this week is not that time and I hope
Brian Schottenheimer turns the ball a
little bit more to Russell Wilson he was
a stud last week coming back against the
Saints he's been a stud for a number of
years now let him throw the football
around against this defense that really
gets confused
utilizing play-action I know of my
betting mind right now is like I wish I
knew the answer to this question because
I know if Seattle comes out and runs it
I'm lovin Arizona plus five and a half
and if they come out and they pass it
it's like who cares about five and a
half points they might get tore up like
they did last week by Kyle Allen it's
just that's the mystery about betting on
football is you're relying on coaches
that have egos and that all of a sudden
the light might go off but I tend to bet
against the light going off just because
I know that coaches are stubborn but
that's why this watch why this is hard
33% is why this is hard homeys because
you have all the information in front of
you and you have the roadmap but you
don't know who's driving the car and
they might not give a [ __ ] about the
road map so it's it's tough sometimes
and that's what makes it fun that's what
makes it unpredictable which brings
excitement to it um obviously it's more
exciting when you're winning your wagers
but it's kind of like the the heartbeat
like if it was too predictable and too
easy you know sports will jack up the
lines and we would never have as much
value and there might not be as much
opportunity to profit but because
there's so many different wrinkles and
edges and we could be ahead of certain
things that's what gives value for us
from a betting perspective and it's what
makes the games very unpredictable and
exciting although sometimes albeit very
frustrating so one other game that moved
this is not a favorite that got juiced
up as we've shown if you take out to
Miami games that's 2 & 9 and then let me
just repeat that the the favorites that
got juiced up since the look-ahead lines
Ravens went from three and a half to six
and a half hosting the Browns Chiefs
went from four and a half to six and a
half at the Lions Patriots went four up
that was not a juiced-up one Seahawks
went from three to five and a half at
Arizona
an example of a line that shrunk but a
team is still the favorite bears went
from three to one and a half point
favorites hosting the Lions and I went
back and I would love Warren's work so
much that I wrote it all down into a doc
and I check it from time to time and one
of them was this statistic since 2004
when the Vikings are playing an outdoor
road game at a team with a 500 record or
better they are zero ten and one and
this is a game where it's happening and
so I see a statistic and again these are
trends and trends are not something that
Warren cares that much about because he
is a smarter guy than me
I hear trends were a team that hasn't
won an outdoor game against a team 500
or better and I go take me to the window
and so here we have the line where the
Bears have gone from three to one and a
half but do you put a lot into that
statistic or am I just getting too
excited because I'm a noob no I mean
look that's a particular statistic that
does that should resonate a little bit
and you should factor in a I was the one
who came up with that like looking at
that angle and it is it is a concern I
mean Mike Zimmer's teams have not played
that many road teams that are winning
records did not play many games outdoors
like this and those opponents tend to do
pretty well obviously the the line move
is telling you that Minnesota has been
taking some money but it looks like
that's also some there's a very public
side which is rare when you see a team
like the Bears go out and absolutely
dominate the residence or multiple
quarters in that game the Redskins it
was like in half timer they're gonna
fire Jay Gruden that's how bad the
Redskins were looking and then they come
back late in that game and all of a
sudden you know people don't want to bet
on the Bears this week against the
Vikings to me it's like this beautiful
thing by the way 64% of public money
right now is on Minnesota clearly
dropping the line from three to one and
a half for the Bears but it's so funny
that a team dominates the first half and
because mental chore Biscay threw an
interception to Josh Norman in the red
zone when that happened it became an
online cacophony of
try Biscay I'm watching Orlovsky
battling people on Twitter I'm seeing
you know other ESPN talent like Louis
ridic have to defend her Biscay people
are waiting to dive in and say you were
drafted ahead of deshaun Watson a
Bachelor Holmes you're not good and they
looked over the fact that wow they're up
28 to 3 like it was nothing and in a
weird way it skewed the public because
it was a standalone Monday night game
and we're looking at a Minnesota team
that yes they've looked phenomenal
against the Raiders and the Falcons at
home but in their game against the
Packers Kirk Cousins was throwing bad
interceptions and if you take away a 75
yard touchdown from Dalvin cook his
statistics are a lot more average so it
kind of I opened to the fact that oh and
by the way Travis Keyes home road splits
are like so wild that at home at this
time of the year he's good it just it
piques my interest warren sharp it
piques my interest as it should we've
talked about here though that yeah
Mitchell true Biscay has that nike
schemed around some of the weaknesses of
Mitchell Travis key he's worked around
those because Mitch does struggle in
certain areas passing the football and
opposing defenses are starting to figure
that out a little bit more so a defense
like Mike Zimmer is gonna be fascinating
to see what he's figured out with one
year to really study these two together
from the 2018 season what he's gonna do
in terms of changing things this
upcoming game against them defensively
but you the other factor is of course
Taylor Gabriel I think who caught three
touchdowns he's gonna I think he's gonna
be out I don't know he's dealing with a
concussion right Adam so what he'd come
back and practice on Friday or not if he
can't then most likely he's gonna be out
though there is a small chance that he
could be ruled back in so good the Bears
are dealing with a couple of injuries
too but you're absolutely right I mean
the Minnesota Vikings
they're an interesting team playing on
the road outdoors should be very
fascinating just for I just looked this
up I just want to clarify
Mitchell sure Biscay at home against the
Vikings
get some statistics out there 2017 is
rookie year when he was kind of coming
up 128 yards one touchdown one
interception Vikings win 20 to 17 and
that was a Vikings team that went on not
a pretty good season went on to the NFC
Championship game to lose to the Eagles
2018
it was a five-point Bears win against
the Vikings Travis key though 165 yards
one touchdown two interceptions so I
just want to say this one more time
sure Biscay throws for 165 one touchdown
two interceptions and they beat the
Vikings by five in Chicago like he
didn't even play well and they won that
game by five so for me this is more
about the what are we gonna see on the
Vikings offense in Chicago then what are
we gonna see from Travis key because
they've already they've had success
against this team it's just it's
interesting am I reading too much into
it anytime I go too far I need you to go
Adam you're being a noob no you're not
reading too much into it and I remember
that game clearly in that game Kirk
Cousins really struggle I think he threw
an interception into the end zone you
know so Kirk Cousins that's the other
thing we're talking a lot about Mitchell
Travis Keyes yeah we also should be OB
accounting for Kirk Cousins going up
against this past defense how about this
past defense and they just lost their
slot receiver and Chad Beebe and they're
bringing back laQuan Treadwell who
hasn't been on the team in four weeks
this is a team that has had a lot of
success when that running game gets
going but the one injury that I think
I'm going to be paying attention to
before I get too excited about this game
is probably gonna be a key mix because I
think a key mix we saw him walking off
he was day-to-day Leonard Floyd was
day-to-day I'm going to pay attention to
the injury reports again we're recording
this on Thursday smart betters wait
until Friday or Saturday when we see
three practices if a key mix is a DMP DM
PDMP I'm gonna get a little scared
because I want that depth at the same
point I know there are steps in the
depth of the Bears but I want to make
sure I think that's the fair way to go
about this one I think so too and don't
underestimate how big of a game this is
this is you know that the Green Bay
Packers you got to keep pace
with the Green Bay Packers who obviously
are in the tops of the division right
now and both of these two teams this
could be go a long way especially for
Chicago of having a shot at winning this
division because Minnesota is going to
be a team that's probably gonna be in
this thing at the end as well and
head-to-head schedule could be massive
how big of a deal is the Monday Night
Football versus Sunday the six day short
week is there anything with that of the
impact that has um there is a little bit
of a factor it's never great when you're
playing on the road and you have to do a
little bit of extra traveling most of
these teams have already figured out
their game plans prior to that Monday
night so they already know like what
they're gonna do against the Vikings but
it's rest for the players and adjustment
and all of those types of things where
you want to tweak that game plan based
upon the last game you want to get your
players a little bit of Health so it's
never ideal it's not crippling however
it's it feels like it's a lot safe
though if you play Monday Night Football
and then your next game is at home is
that a lot better than a Monday football
and then a trip yeah I mean the best
scenario is home home you're home on
Monday night and then you're home again
but yes I think you're a slightly better
situation when you're not doing the
traveling after a road Monday night game
so the two games that were exciting me
the most in the one o'clock slate was
Chiefs liens and patriots bills I pretty
sure that we tackled everything there I
don't think there was any notes you had
that were in addition to that the only
other prime time was there anything else
you had no I think you're right the only
other prime time game though that I
think has caught a lot of sharp money
and I think it's one of the more
interesting games of the week is Cowboys
Saints Cowboys right now two and a half
point favorites at the Saints and with
Teddy Bridgewater and with the Saints
coming off of a fumble return touchdown
and a punt return touched or kick return
touchdown I think it was a punt return
touchdown it's called a lot of sharp
money right now Dallas I'm seeing
getting about 57% of the money the other
thing though is looking at this matchup
from last year
feel like you could have grasped a lot
of information from the week 13 game or
is the same situation Dallas went to New
Orleans what did we see in that game
that we can use for this matchup the big
thing to me in that game was the amount
of pressure that drew brees the
quarterback at the time for the Saints
was under in that game Drew Brees was
under pressure left and right from the
stylist Cowboys defense and what he
ended up having to do which is pretty
unique is he had to throw 14 passes to
his running back so the way that he
split up his passing because of that
pressure and him needing get the ball
out of his hands quickly is he threw 14
passes to wide receivers and 14 passes
to running backs 0-2 tight ends and
those 14 passes two running backs
includes Alvin Kamara one of the most
dynamic running backs in the league
catching the ball out of the backfield
out of those 40 passes only one of them
produced a successful game that's seven
percent and that the average 2.9 yards
per attempt so they had a terrible time
trying to pass the ball to Alvin Kamara
the Cowboys defense was really good
defending those types of passes and you
know the wide receivers it just wasn't
enough they weren't able to like move
the ball enough I remember that game in
addition to the pressure it was how many
punts how many times the Saints were
going three and out three and out three
and al Sean Payton's a proud guy he is
going to come in with some adjustments
but the problem is he can't make those
adjustments with Drew Brees he's trying
to make those adjustments with Teddy
Bridgewater and there's a significant
you know drop-off in production that you
can expect out if you're passing eight
when you're dealing with Teddy
Bridgewater instead of Drew Brees I was
surprised one of the things we talked
about on the show last week was that the
Saints would go in with Sean Payton to
Seattle and utilize a lot more Taysom
Hill and work him into the passing
attack but they didn't use him at all
and whether that was they had a lead and
they didn't think they needed to
incorporate him into the mix so they're
putting him on the side and gonna work
some magic this game and save them for
this one or it was a situation where
they don't have a third-string
quarterback and they wanted to make sure
that like they won't get guys
you taste them gets hurt or Teddy gets
hurt and then you don't have a backup
um they were trying to save him from
that perspective I'm not sure what this
situation was but at the end of the day
it's not going to get any easier for the
Saints and we know how much more dynamic
the offense is for the Dallas Cowboys
we know how bad the Saints defense has
been against they'll focus on that
because I think in this matchup people
like to focus on the Saints offense and
against the Dallas defense but this year
we're seeing such a different Dallas
defense Dallas offense and I will say
this about the Saints I find their
defensive line to be very impactful I
think they can generate a lot of rush
cam Jordan as a phenomenal player it's
the back end it's the second error in
these linebacker issues Saints are
having to bring in Stephane Anthony a
former first-round pick that they kind
of cut a few years ago when he's floated
around the league but they lost Alex
Anzalone II and I'm looking at this
Dallas team and they're different uses
of formation their way that everyone
needs to be afraid of Zeek it's what
they're building off of Zeek that's so
interesting so I feel very confident in
Dallas defense I believe they have the
two linebackers that they can look at
camara and go if he goes left
Jaylon Smith you got him if he goes
right Vander Esch you got him
Oh your other option is Michael Thomas I
got Byron Jones who's so much more
athletic than Michael Thomas it's gonna
be a hard day's work but now I got a
Dallas offense that I think could really
make life tough for the Saints defense
and they're not coached by Sean Payton
no and the Dallas offense is getting
tremendous productivity the the problem
with it they're super productive in
every single personnel grouping and
they're mixing it up they're using 11
they're using 12 they're using 21
they're even getting in a little bit of
13 with three tight end sets a couple
plays out of 20 I mean they're very
diverse with the personnel deployment
and they're very good with the post snap
motion their their their play action
game and those are things that are gonna
affect this Saints defense I mean the
Saints we were surprised you know week
one we took the Houston Texans against
the Saints and one of the things that I
wasn't
sure house +7 it was beautiful and how
well is Carlos Hyde gonna run the books
I don't really love Carlos Hyde he was
cutting that's a good thing and so
Carlos Hyde can cut you up like that
what do you think this cowboy's
offensive line with Zeke might be able
to do and then if you try to come up and
stop that we know that what color mores
bringing to the table
play action deeper shots spreading the
ball around obviously we know that the
Dallas Cowboys are down one of their
wide receivers but in Michael Gallup but
this is still a team that's very
balanced has a lot of ability to be
explosive in the air with Amari Cooper
yes it's going to be a challenge for the
Saints defense I think the thing to
that's very interesting to me and this
is more me watching football and it's
it's so I'm diving too deep into one
thing but Dallas as a team I watched
Teddy Bridgewater in the locker room
almost crying saying thank you to
everybody last week was an emotional win
for the Saints it was the first win it
was our first game without Drew Brees it
was the first start for Teddy
Bridgewater really since that injury and
it meant something and there's a release
that comes with that
the Dallas Cowboys were up 10 to 6 on
the Miami Dolphins at halftime they went
out there and tried to destroy that team
and they got caught up and the Dolphins
even ran a flea-flicker and that went to
Preston Williams and call me crazy but
when a team has some some trick plays
run against him that next practice
everybody's tight and that next practice
they're going you think that you can be
in halftime ten six against the Dolphins
and we're gonna go in in New Orleans you
know what Sean Payton's gonna do
ivenn they're gonna be ready for every
trick play I think Dallas at almost
every level is a more athletic team than
the New Orleans Saints and I think that
I I look at the sames last week and I
felt like they exploded and I I just
don't see it so I kind of have five
picks but they're very much based off
your analytics right now I'm obviously
gonna watch the injury reports but these
are the five ways that I'm leaning in
the super contest and I'm realizing that
most of them are
games that are coming from the huge line
movements but tell me if I'm crazy I've
liked Dallas - two and a half the entire
time it's it's a side that I know it's
with sharp money I kind of think it's
gonna grow even further as this week
goes on I really like Buffalo plus seven
against New England I like I kind of
like Arizona plus five and a half I'm
just a little scared of it
but I love the home fields but when I
said so far those three are you in
alignment with those three or am I
getting a little scary and and kind of
enjoying this information too much I
don't think you're getting scary the one
thing I will add to your narrative which
is kind of like the narrative capping of
the Saints game is that was a very
astute point that you actually brought
up and something 33% should start to
factor in when you have quarterback
injuries oftentimes what happens is we
get a very game effort that very first
game that that backup has to enter the
situation the whole team steps up and I
think we it cannot go under discussed
how the New Orleans Saints stayed out
west away from the distractions of their
families between the game at the Rams
and the game in Seattle they had the
opportunity to bond with Teddy
Bridgewater a quarterback devised the
best style of office all these reasons
last week we shared why we liked the
Saints last week but you take all that
and then you go back home with all your
families you're feeling yourself a
little bit I think that that is a factor
and definitely like the second game with
that backup quarterback typically there
is there can be a little bit of a
drop-off that will be a very sharp
versus square game there's no doubt
about it I think that a lot of people
are going to be betting on the Dallas
Cowboys there but it looks like a like a
team that we're playing if you're taking
Dallas you're playing against a Saints
team that probably inflated their score
by those two defensive scores and looked
a little bit better than what they
actually were and it's never a bad thing
to kind of say hey maybe I don't want to
be on this team
this very next week the other two I
definitely see your logic in those for
sure and then I would say so I've
already said Buffalo plus seven Arizona
plus five and a half
Dallas minus two and a half and the
other - I'm leaning to R I am leaning to
Cleveland plus six and a half I don't I
don't see this story getting destroyed
I'm seeing an angry Baker Mayfield and
all this stuff and it is a divisional
game and for a line movement to change
by three points with a Ravens defense
that I think might be susceptible it's
one that I kind of like the value there
is that crazy for me even though I know
I'm betting against the coach no I don't
think it's crazy look I was probably
gonna change to be honest yeah and I
don't think Freddie kitchens is a bad
coach I just think he's coaching with
where he thinks his strength is he
thinks his strength is those three wives
so that's why he's putting him out there
I think he I'm hoping he'll make some
adjustments but I don't I don't
necessarily think he's a he's a bad
coach the other thing we will say is
like putting an offensive coordinator I
mean Freddie kitchens was a running back
coach then he moved to an offensive
coordinator calling plays now he's the
head coach there's a lot of new
responsibilities on his shoulder it's
very difficult thing in the NFL to have
that cap and wear it he needs to get
really good really quick at being able
to manage his time better as well as
being willing to pass responsibilities
and tasks yeah there's the the last one
that I kind of like is I like Carolina
plus four and a half at the Texans I
just I think it's a good matchup I don't
think that I think this offense might
actually get continue to be efficient
with Kyle Allen and I look at the Texans
and I see a game in which they won and a
lot of people are excited about going
from west coast back to Houston and I
just think it's a good matchup for a
Carolina defense that I think a lot of
people are sleeping on there's a
Carolina defense that shut down Jared
Goff there's a Carolina defense that
destroyed Cuyler Murray and it's a
Carolina defense that did really well
against the Bucks it was more of a Cam
Newton thing that was the issue so I
like the matchup there that one I feel a
lot more confident
to be honest yeah and keep in mind what
have we seen with the Turner's down in
Carolina when cam was healthy last year
this team kicked ass and when cam got
hurt last season and was playing injured
for a little while remember he was
playing through the shoulder issue and
it wasn't going so well they didn't
obviously look good what would have what
have we seen weeks 1 & 2 it was Cam
Newton coming back from that same
shoulder surgery that he got he didn't
look that accurate he certainly couldn't
run the football cuz he had a foot
injury and you weren't getting the
efficiency out of that quarterback
position now you poked Kyle Allen in
there a guy who can run a little bit a
guy who can throw the ball and lo and
behold they're doing pretty well so I
think here's an interesting one where
you don't just take the Cam Newton
splits take the Cam Newton health versus
not health and take a look at what this
team the Carolina Panthers was able to
do when cam was healthy versus when he's
been banged up and injured but still
trying to play through that I think
you'll be surprised we're gonna call
crack now my proxy in Las Vegas again he
is available from the crack winds app
and so what I asked for you two guys to
do is if you want to check it out the
crack wins app you get his weekly picks
along with great betting tips strategies
and insider content he is entering my
picks in the super contest and Warren oh
no if I told you I'm ten and five in the
super contest we're doing pretty well
hey crack how are you good
I was just telling Warren that I'm ten
and five which means I'm pretty much in
the top thirty three percent of the
super contest which is kind of beautiful
I dig it that's great no you're really
doing great that's uh you know it's
amazing I was talking about this before
it's amazing to me some of these guys
that are like in almost others there's
guys on beaten in these pools I think
the other one has like thirty guys that
are like with one loss like Wow between
the both of them these guys it resists
so much of a luck factor that it really
is great to be in the top percentile
like you said ten and five you keep on
doing that you're gonna get a paycheck
we got to
is there payouts that are not just the
top payout oh yeah there's really I
didn't know this all the way down oh
yeah oh yeah this payouts there's pay I
think they pay out a hundred people or
something like they actually it's funny
we're in this contest we don't even know
I'm pretty sure that there's uh top
hundred guys or something like that on
that answer for you for next week's war
what were you about to say I think it
stopped it used to be okay oh yeah it's
to be top twenty and the whole year was
top twenty I finished 21st oh that was
like all right yeah I think it stopped
they expanded it now and I think it's
top fifty oh yeah I think that is
amazing week you're gonna get paid yeah
we feel good but I'll tell you what it's
this show is is not we're not touting
you know I mean we're not telling people
that these are guarantees and I think
the fact that we can all sit here and
marvel at the fact that there's a lumber
of people that have gone 15 and oh and
14 and 1 they're sitting at home right
now thinking they're geniuses and what's
really funny is is if they went 5 and 10
the next three weeks if I went five and
two in the next three weeks I would not
be shocked because that's how hard it is
to do this stuff crack let me give you
the if not answer the five games that
I'm leaning towards right now and again
I will text you tomorrow night and then
to all the people out there I will
update on Twitter add Adam left Co what
my entries will be for the super contest
because the ones I'm given right now
they may change due to injury they may
change just because I'm gonna go home
and research more but the five games are
leaning towards are Dallas - two and a
half crack Dallas - two and a half is a
New Orleans big primetime game for New
Orleans that opened it's three and a
half actually down to two and a half now
so you know it's going to be that old
home dog situation of course the
quarterback not being there on the
whirlings Dallas playing pretty good so
you know but I gotta tell you I'm
staying away from that game because
Dallas I think they played the warren on
those better than me
I think Dallas played Miami of course we
know where Miami Giants and Washington's
yep you're right so maybe I know they're
picked as one of not just America's Team
but one of the good teams this year so
I'll be ruler there that's yeah and
again that's why I appreciate you
because I'm gonna go back and reevaluate
that one
I like Buffalo plus seven hosting New
England I like I like Carolina plus four
and a half at Houston okay okay Euston
just come off beating the Chargers
Carolina you know beat an Arizona team
is that okay I would agree with that I
thought I didn't I don't have that game
the Buffalo game though just to go back
to that real quick this is a giant game
for Buffalo they're playing three you
know the crowds go to crazy they're
gonna coming home for this game playing
against the super power you know I don't
know if Warner would know this I don't
know if going was 100% really healthy
of course Devlin but Edelman Brady III
don't know how healthy those guys are no
pretty little casting of course he's
playing but so I think it's a big spot
for Buffalo I'm even looking at maybe
some money the line out here I love it
Brian Westbrook on show also thinks he's
going Buffalo with a win which I love
and then my last two again these are
subject to change
Arizona plus five-and-a-half hosting
Seattle and Cleveland plus six and a
half going to Baltimore and I love
Baltimore that just feels like a field
goal game to me you know I talk about
what a friend of mine what your picks
are gonna be what I think they're going
to be I thought you were gonna pick
Baltimore is it do you like it more or
less than I took Cleveland well you know
I think Cleveland is not who we thought
they were going to be and and then we're
seeing now Baltimore you know they're
there it's six and a half minus 20 now
it's seven in a couple spots so the line
with taking Cleveland maybe a little bit
you know listen the offseason hype
machine was all Browns
and it's kind of appealed away and
they're showing their kind of an average
team well this is a big big spot for
themselves
I'll be rooting for you there any any
games that I didn't say that crack has
his eye on Detroit
everyone loves Casey the
churches come off a big win in Philly
this could be kind of a letdown game
this is gonna be a look down game for
Kansas City everyone thinking that
they're like Super Bowl contenders I
notice I know a sharp syndicate group
that just bet Detroit out here plus six
and a half so I'm gonna I'm gonna
include your troit on my on my picks but
I'm with you on Buffalo zoo that's what
I'm doing them so yeah
Aparri crack I'm gonna be texting your
buddy and we will do this together
you're the man dude again crack wins at
weekly picks great betting tips
strategies insider content and to be
honest me and Warren talk about this a
lot me and Warren care about one thing
more than anything and that's good
[ __ ] people because we both are
psychopaths we were talking last night
and about 2:45 in the morning and Warren
goes I'm gonna hang up the phone
I have more work to do we we really only
like doing the thing we like this we
like talking about the games and we know
that it's not an exact science but when
you guys are in our mentions a 33% the
homies and you're sending us tickets or
you just appreciate the information
that's the reason we're doing it so
Warren I appreciate you brother I I mean
this when I say this and I just wanted
on the record that nobody puts in more
[ __ ] effort than Warren this is not
some [ __ ] social media Twitter
Instagram thing where he finds
information and he hides in the closet
and like no like this man [ __ ] grinds
and I respect it
is there anything else you want to get
out information wise or just anything in
general mr. sharp no I think we're good
feeling pretty positive about this card
this week and you know hopefully you
guys are gonna be able to take some of
what we're sharing and then watch the
game with a little bit of a different I
don't care so much about what the
announcers say try to think back to this
show some of the things I would take
notes Adams so good at this this is one
of his real good qualities very
organized takes a lot of notes so he
knows what to look for I would advise
you guys to be going through this
podcast and and taking notes on
everything that we're doing here and
saying
and then watching the games and see if
you're noticing and picking up on some
of those things because there's nothing
better for me at least than to watch
games and have a different perspective
heading into that game than I thought I
would have and learning something from
it
awesome yeah I think I think that's the
key and then again pay attention I will
tweet out the actual super contest pics
a little bit later but this weekend will
be really great and again you can get
20% off Warren sharps website and and
that's possible for like to get your
picks for Sunday right yeah I mean we do
fantasy football we do prop betting but
we also do my wage ring everything that
I'm giving out to my clients privately
at sharp football analysis yeah you
could use the code sharp 20 I'm not
gonna advertise that anywhere else is
just for you guys and he went off I had
no last week but it's a weirdly shaped
ball but let me just say that it wasn't
a weirdly shaped 5a know it was pretty
solid right down the middle sharp you're
the freakin man to go out oh we're doing
the other music which means we're saving
the cash register I'm gonna download it
I'm gonna listen to it on the way home
Warren you're the man obviously follow
sharp at sharp football on Twitter be
well my friend all right peace out
always
[Music]